so Donald Trump had an interview with
Fox News and in that interview Fox News
he started describing his first 100 days
now we're gonna play that a clip of that
later on but I just found it hilarious
that he's positioning himself as being
the most accomplished president in the
first 100 days Pat I think the most that
he's accomplished in his first 100 days
is a massive amount of flip-flopping I
mean we have we have records of them
flip-flopping on almost every major
issue but let's start with the flip-flop
from yesterday with regard to NATO in a
joint press conference this is what he
said about NATO the secretary-general
and I had a productive discussion about
what more NATO can do in the fight
against terrorism
I complained about that a long time ago
and they made a change and now they do
fight terrorism I said it was obsolete
it's no longer obsolete all right so
this he made big hey about over this
during the election during the primary
and the election he considered NATO to
be obsolete he considered them not to be
carrying certain countries not to be
carrying their own weight and all of a
sudden now he says they are they're no
longer obsolete I guess because he says
so well I think just about everyone will
have a change of opinion on any given
topic as they learn more about the world
and as they get older but Donald Trump
is a 70 year old man you think he'd be
pretty set in his ways at this point and
yeah you're right it's just about every
issue well so I mean you said something
very important there that I want to
highlight the more he learns about an
issue the more likely he is to flip-flop
on it and we have a couple of examples
here of all the major issues at least on
foreign policy that he's flip-flopped on
in the last almost 100 days Syria you
know we talked about this yesterday
where now he is he bombed Syria versus
having a non interventionist position
the export-import bank I don't know if
you recall during the election he
basically said that that that was no
good and it served no purposes but he
came out to say once he learned about it
this is the key thing once he learned
about it he said it turns out that first
of all lots of small companies are
really helped by the export-import bank
the vendor companies and actually that's
his complete sentence
it makes no sense but that's his
complete sentence but he went on to say
but also maybe more important the other
countries give assistance when other
countries I'd give it we lose a
tremendous amount of business
instinctively you would say it's a
ridiculous thing but actually it's a
very good thing and it actually makes
money it can make a lot of money so this
is him after finally learning just a
little bit about what the export-import
big is he flips on that issue also
reminds me of when Chris Matthews asked
Donald Trump whether or not women should
be punished if they have abortions and
just because Trump wasn't really prepped
on that question he said yes which is a
position that even pro lifers aren't
willing to take right and he's also just
going to read the room so during the
campaign the proposition to jail Hillary
Clinton played over really well with the
crowds after he won the election not so
much he realized he should back off of
that right and he's in it and you you've
given the entire thesis of this segment
the more he learns about something the
more likely he has a establishment
position on it with ricotta bout NATO
Syria the export-import bank Russia as a
whole you know he still wants to have a
generally good relationship with Russia
but his position is shifting or at least
his administration's position is
shifting with regard to Janet Yellen of
the Federal Reserve he once described
her as being toast he's now saying she's
no longer toast
so he's flip-flopped on that he's
flip-flopped on the national debt he
made this this ridiculous promise that
he was going to be able to get rid of
the national debt in four years his
budget director Mick Mulvaney said this
is impossible and that Donald Trump was
clearly being hyperbolic to me this is
just an example of someone who's out of
power making all of these promises gets
into power and realizes it's a little
more complicated than he thought and
then he changes his mind and sometimes
they're not just 180 degree flip flops
sometimes he comes full circle show for
the torture issue for example he was Pro
torture and then general mattis for a
time convinced him that the carrot
method works a little bit better than
the stick method and we shave waterboard
people for example and since then it's
been a couple months so now he's coming
back to the idea that torture is a good
thing
well the last thing that he's made the
perfect example of what you said at the
beginning of the segment of the
more he learns about it the more likely
he is to change his position on it is
regard to the relationship with China he
decided not to label China a currency
manipulator that was a major shift this
is one of his number-one things that he
said during the election is that you
know America the China is a currency
manipulator but now he realizes the
relationship with China and he said that
he needs to have a good relationship
with China so that they can help with
North Korea which actually digs into a
deeper problem of a lack of
understanding for Donald Trump because
he went to President Xi and explained
that President Xi and China needs to do
more with regard to to North Korea and
he actually said that after 10 minutes
of listening to President Xi on the
issue of the real relationship between
North Korea and China
he realized that China doesn't have as
much sway over North Korea as he had
hoped so he's learning on the job making
empty promises during the campaign
learning on the job and all of these
positions have completely flip-flopped
and during the campaign people thought
he was bold to say that he would label
China as a currency manipulator and so
many other examples
everyone thought well you know he's an
outsider he's not a politician that's
why he's willing to make these claims
and statements it turns out he just
didn't know the policy well enough yeah
it it's it's kind of it's amazing that
we are giving President Trump this
learning on the job curve and every time
he learns a little bit more about the
world the more he confirmed conforms to
the establishment position some for
better some for worse right there's some
issues that that he might not have been
wrong on and we could dig into it and it
probably not a good time to dig into all
of it but it's just it's hilarious that
he's at this beginning entry level of
learning about the world he's not even
at the point where he actually gets
disillusioned from what he learns about
the world he's still impressed with a
little bit of things that he's learning
like anybody with Google in ten minutes
could have understood that China does
not have as much sway over North Korea
as one would think
but he's blown away because ten minutes
of listening President Xi he realized
that this entire position was faulty so
he flipped on it and I'd venture to say
that President of the United States is
not one of those jobs where you can just
learn by doing and learn
as you go it's a little bit too
prestigious and important for some
important to important of a job but that
you know if he's accomplished anything
over the last 100 days it has been a
series of major flip flops and I'm just
curious as to who was still standing
behind him after he's flipped on so many
issues that were important to them I
think it works out good for the world in
many regards but for his supporters not
so much